speaking of the 2022 election
Rolling Stone has an incredible report
out about the Trump plan it's an active
plan to try to steal the 2022 election
now you might be saying well steal it
steal it in what way because Republicans
may do quite well in the 2022 election
Rolling Stone reports that Donald Trump
has quote convened a series of in-person
meetings and conference calls to discuss
laying the groundwork to challenge the
2022 midterm election results during
these meetings and these conference
calls quote pro-trump groups attorneys
Republican party activists and Maga
diehards often discuss the type of
scorched Earth legal tactics they could
deploy now this is for elections they
don't win specifically understand that
this is not about let's come together it
sounds so stupid because it's so
unbelievable let's come to let's do
something good for democracy let's come
together to ensure that the rightful
winner as determined by the will of the
people actually wins every single
election
that's my Tucker Carlson laugh
that's not what they want that's not
what they want this is for elections
they don't win let's figure out what
sort of tactics we can use to try to get
some of these anyway they came close in
2020 and they're not giving up one route
that they reportedly planned to take
says Rolling Stone is to do the exact
same thing on Election night that Trump
tried in those early hours of the 2020
election which is you come out and you
say there has been fraud or fraud As
Trump says
uh I won this is embarrassing we're
winning this election and remember
frankly we did win this election those
chilling words at 2 A.M were you didn't
win anything what are you talking about
frankly we did win this election that is
one tool that they are looking to employ
maybe with more favorable district
courts secretaries of State Governors
Etc
the report from Rolling Stone is that
Trump is very focused on Pennsylvania
including Oz V fetterman we already
talked extensively about that race
earlier and the internal dynamics of
that race why would Trump care so much
about Pennsylvania it should be obvious
at this point 2024
is the reason why in 2024 Pennsylvania
could determine who is the next
president of the United States and
certainly having your guy in as a
senator who could potentially object to
the counting of the electoral votes in
the uh in January of 2025 is useful also
having a governor in Doug mastriano who
chooses the Secretary of State who
oversees the election in 2024 would be
very very useful I'm increasingly
wondering what if any connection there
is between the armed Intimidators
outside of Arizona ballot boxes and this
Trump movement I don't know I'm just
asking the question and what you have to
understand is that at the end of the day
their proposals make no sense
they don't have that many options left
but to cheat and steal look at some of
the things they're proposing a National
Abortion ban that's completely unpopular
at a time when Roe v Wade is as popular
as it has been over a 50-year period now
you're going to say National Abortion
ban that doesn't make sense so instead
you go to cheating and stealing doing
nothing about gun violence and actually
proposing more guns in more places
despite constant mass shootings that
doesn't make a lot of sense so then you
go to well we can cheat and we can steal
looking at gutting and cutting Social
Security and Medicare
when older voters are demographically
they're bread and butter that doesn't
make sense so you figure out ways to
cheat and steal
if they can get away with it they're
going to try or rather I should say
they're going to try and they may be
able to get away with it and if you want
to get a sense of the level of delusion
here
let's go to Jon Stewart's incredible
interview that is going to be published
in full very very soon